for someone who says he wants privacy
we've heard a lot from Prince Harry
lately interviews a Netflix documentary
and most recently his tell-all books
spare we've heard about his rivalry with
his brother Rouse with his dad the king
and he shared some pretty personal
details about his life like when he lost
his virginity in a field behind a pub at
17.
but is all that really a sideshow
because Prince Harry is about to begin
what he's described as his life's work
reforming the British press who he says
have made his life a misery for the last
two decades
he's accusing several tabloid newspapers
of phone hacking placing tracking
devices on cars and even bugging hotel
rooms not just his but those of his
friends and family too I can understand
why he's angry all the things that
happened to his mother
and when things happen to your family
you know that's what people do they go
to war
I think he is at War I don't think it's
a campaign I think he is at War
I'm Sally Lockwood and this is the Sky
News Daily
The Voice you heard just then was Graham
Johnson he worked at some of the
newspapers Harry's accusing During the
period he alleged phone hacking was
going on we'll hear more from him in
just a minute but first i'm joined in
the studio by our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock
Laura great to see you Prince Harry is
of course a story that you know we keep
talking about because there are new
developments all the time and now of
course accusations against a number of
newspapers what's he claiming I mean
look we've been hearing a lot about
Prince Harry haven't we ever since he
stopped being a working member of the
royal family but bubbling away in the
background were always these cases he
had against the British tabloid press it
is no secret the extent of his hatred of
the tabloids and now we're starting to
see these cases
most likely come to court and there are
three major cases that he is involved in
and they are against the Publishers of
the mail the mail on Sunday Mail online
Publishers of the Sun and people used to
publish the news of the world and the
Publishers of the mirror as well and so
these three separate but huge cases are
coming to court and we're starting to
get a sense by looking at what's going
on in these cases of how and I use the
word agree if it doesn't even go far
enough really how angry how frustrated
how how he wants to do something to
tackle this now and and this this all
these papers here is what he's doing and
you know from from what I've read he
doesn't want to settle out of court he
wants to be heard and some of the
allegations are pretty explosive so all
of these cases and it's worth pointing
out of the three of them we only really
know the details when it comes to the
cases against the the mirror group
newspapers and the News Group newspapers
as well because the one involving
Associated Publishers of the mail Etc we
haven't got that information that that's
not been released but what we do know
and we are getting a sense of the extent
that he says his phone was hacked uh
that his landline was tapped that rooms
were bugged that cars were being
followed and it wasn't just for him
personally but people really close to
him so his brother for example but I
think what stands out is a lot about
Chelsea Davey his then girlfriend and
how it was a constant thing with her and
you can just for example look at this is
the this these are some of the papers
from the case
um Duke of Sussex and News Group
newspapers that's the purpose of the Sun
and what was then the news of the world
and you can see the number of payments
that have been made related to Chelsea
Davey there is Page upon page upon page
and some of these payments are for sort
of small sums of money some of them run
into the thousands of pounds such was
the value of this kind of information
information he says was all legally
obtained just to give listeners an idea
Laura's flicking through a really large
document of of claims and allegations
and and what payments is it that that
are detailed in that payments to who it
varies there is a range but pray
payments to people who are acting as
private investigators people who were
photographers some sort of freelance
journalists as well and you perhaps get
a sense as I say of the value of things
when you look at I mean just an example
I've highlighted here there was a
payment dated the 18th of November 2007
the title was Chelsea p15 pick urgent
and that was a 6 000 pound payment so
whatever that that bit of information
was had had a huge value but as I say
Harry says it had this huge impact on
his life his personal relationships
suffered incredibly it led to this sense
of huge General paranoia distrusting
people people around him and he believes
that those who were at the very top got
away with it basically so this is his
moment I think to try and redress that
but about five or six pups
who were literally multi-millionaires
during this period who used to fly
around the world taking pictures of
Prince Harry Prince William and the
royal family and their their Associates
and what's becoming clear now is they
relied on information given to them by
private investigators
this is Graham Johnson he worked in
tabloid newspapers for more than two
decades during the 90s and naughties the
same period Prince Harry is accusing
some of these newspapers of repeatedly
invading his privacy and while Graham
was investigations editor at the Sunday
Mirror he says on one occasion he was
asked to tap a phone line by his Deputy
editor
well years later Graham reported it to
the police pled guilty and was convicted
for phone hacking
now he uses his investigative skills to
try to uncover wrongdoing by other
journalists he explained to me why
newspapers were willing to spend so much
money and take such risk to track down
celebrities like Prince Harry the
rewards were so high that they had to be
right all the time so say for example
you got a tip that Prince Harry was in
Barbados or or whatever right now before
you pay for flights and hotels for your
packs and for your news reporters and
for you know their Entourage and so on
it's cost effective for you to pay a
private investigator
to find out if that's right to
corroborated so they would
they would have people at Heathrow
Airport and they would have specialists
uh investigators able to track planes
and track passengers uh all over the
world by getting into the Manifest of
various Airlines and then you could also
get into their phones you know phone
hacking and listening to voicemails and
you'd be able to find out where they are
by listening to their messages and then
also you could ping them private
investigators would get into the plug
into the phone companies
and they would be able to find out where
Prince Harry was on a GPS system you
know and then you'd be able to plug the
hotels and all that it was well worth
these multi-millionaire perhaps and
their clients they're paying these
investigators to do it just to clarify
here although some newspapers including
some of those being accused by Prince
Harry like the news of the world have
previously been found guilty of phone
hacking for others the accusations
remain just that accusations
but Graham says he did witness this sort
of thing happening
and Graham from what you saw did people
who were involved in this sort of
activity say editors or even Newsroom
lawyers question the ethics of what they
were doing no no morality didn't really
come into it really on reflection there
was no time for reflection you know it's
a tablet usual and it's reported you
know they move at 800 mile an hour
there's no time to reflect on the Rights
and Wrongs of these decisions and
tabloid editors I mean they definitely
knew
about not all of them not all of them of
course I I work for some really good
answers who weren't involved in in these
practices and also you know the the
lawyers who I knew knew about the legal
use of private investigators and and
that's a big part of Prince Harry's case
against the Miller group The Lawyers
knew about phone hacking and unlawful
information gathering but also the board
allegedly knew about these practices
so what you're saying Graham is that in
your opinion it went all the way to the
very top of these newspapers it wasn't
just a few Rogue journalists and private
investigators who were doing this and
and do you think the levison inquiry
which looked into phone hacking back in
the early 2010s do you think if it
failed to uncover the true extent of all
this I think what the leverson inquiry
didn't uncover is the scale of
I mean I I think it's organized crime
you know I think it's organized crap and
what I mean by that is the scale of it
you know how much money was spent on it
and how many people were involved in it
there were hundreds of people Millions
tens of millions spent on it it was
widespread across newspapers private
investigators huge numbers of targets
thousands of targets at the time it went
on the kind of seriously the criminality
you know the newspapers that are alleged
to have committed burglaries
to get information so yeah it's it's
similar to organized crime which
ironically that was my job at the Sunday
Mirror to investigate to organize crime
drug crime mainly so it wasn't hard for
me to start investigating or less in
2015. do you think Prince Harry's court
cases now will go further and expose
more of what was actually going on yeah
so that's that's the whole point really
so that there was supposed to be a
second part of levison called levison 2
which was due to start a few years ago
and that was going to investigate
further criminality and relations
between newspapers and the police and
and these more Sinister privates
investigators but that got canceled by
mahankook when he was the culture
secretary so what people have had to do
basically the claimants in these civil
cases it's been like an uphill struggle
going through the high court to get all
of this information uh disclosed from
the various newspapers groups and that's
what they've been trying to do is
unearth this themselves in a piecemeal
fashion now what Prince Harry's done
he's kind of taken this process
mainstream because of his status he's a
globally recognized figure and you know
that's put pressure on all kinds of
organizations to take this issue
seriously
and since then hundreds of thousands of
documents have been disclosed
and now if the police became aware of
these documents and the CPS
and certain parts of government they
might wish to to reopen criminal
proceedings
now Prince Harry has said he doesn't
want to settle this out of court he
wants these lawsuits to go ahead
do you think there are former newspaper
editors journalists private
investigators who are nervous about what
might unfold in these Court hearings
yeah of course of course because and
this may come as a surprise to you to
your listeners because most cases get
settled out of court right
because it's too expensive
for the claimant to take it to trial
even if you win under what's called
adverse costs you might get hit with a
four million pound bill now someone like
Prince Harry he's got the financial
clout to be able to take that risk and
therefore that's what makes uh editors
and journalists who are involved in this
quite nervous because if it goes to
trial you know they'll be getting named
at trial in a way it's it's a real shame
that it's had to come to this
because I don't want to see journalists
go to jail I also don't want to see you
know the estimated 200 million pound
which the middle group has spent my
former employers have spent on phone
hacking I don't want to see them have to
spend more because that's just money
taken away from their news budgets they
could employ hundreds of journalists for
this kind of money instead they're
making them redundant so it's a shame
that it's come to this and it's uh my
view is if the papers would have been
open and honest and and and talk
globally about this
it wouldn't it wouldn't have reached the
situation and it certainly wouldn't have
set journalists against journalists I
mean it's very difficult for me you know
I've had to investigate this without
fear or favor and some of the people
who've come across my radar have been my
former colleagues and it's really
difficult for me you know I don't want
to make life miserable for them but it's
the same old story it's the senior
Executives and the bosses and the board
members who get away with this and they
make the the people of the coal face
like me pay for it foreign
[Music]
Graham agrees with Prince Harry that
there's plenty more to be uncovered when
it comes to what went on in tabloid
newsrooms in the past few decades back
to Laura I think for many involved in
these cases there was a feeling that
leveson didn't go far enough that those
senior Executives people who might have
signed off payments and things didn't
end up in prison basically and I think
that's what Harry has made it very clear
in interviews he wants to happen there
was a huge denial obviously from the
newspapers that they've done anything
wrong but I think Harry as he says this
is his life's work he wants to change
the media landscape and even his own
father the King has said you want a
suicide mission attempting this but I
think he feels so strongly that there
were people in the Press who were
breaking the law who were lying he wants
to take it as far as he can and won't
rest until he has and many wouldn't
blame Prince Harry for doing this given
the impact that tabloid intrusion has
had on his life life yeah and I think if
you read his Memoir spare and you know
there's lots of takeaways from that book
and whatever you feel about Harry there
is nobody who could look at him
describing his mother's death and feel
huge sympathy for him he was such a
young boy and he speaks isn't he in
interviews about being in the car with
her she was driving he was a little boy
in the back hounded by Paparazzi and I
think he has never accepted really what
happened to his mother he has never felt
that the journalist the paparazzi who
were trying to take photos at the time
would never really held to account
properly that they should have been and
that he wants to take it this far I
think he cannot settle until this is
sorted or he feels he's had as big ago
as he can at trying to sort this and
it's Prince Harry essentially saying
this isn't Okay this may be the status
quo but it's not okay how much do you
think we could see real change come
about from from this legal
the challenge it's interesting isn't it
and if you speak to people from hacked
off the big campaign group that's been
fighting for a lot of the very high
profile people who who said they had
their phones hacked they will say look
he's just another example of what was
going on without a doubt as I say he
he's a big name for all of this but he
Harry I think will need to be able to
convince people as well so it's one
thing to have a legal decision but he
splits opinion doesn't he regardless of
the legalities of what comes of the or
what doesn't come of these cases they
could all settle who knows but he will
need to bring the people with him if
they want to affect proper change but I
think there is a hope certainly from
many campaigners privacy campaigners
that it could bring about some change
but for Harry personally it's much
riskier for him I think I mean it's we
don't get mems the royal family going in
court it just doesn't happen it was
really really unusual anyway I mean is
it risky it's risky for him what's he
got to lose well I think he's got a few
risks I mean there I mean there is a
risk just Naturally by putting himself
in court members of the Royal Family do
not go in court they don't want to be
there so it's really unusual to see him
taking this stance in the first place I
mean financially he's putting himself at
risk because by refusing to accept any
settlements you know there is a
financial cost does he need the money no
does he have the money to pay for this
yes he does we know he's made a lot of
money since he's been giving interviews
the Netflix series the book Etc but I
think it was a big arrest to him as well
and that is his reputation as a
reputational risk really because I think
to many people perhaps he is seen as
this person certainly in the in Britain
who has left the royal family under a
cloud and in terms of his own PR and
trying perhaps to to win over support
here which he will need if he wants to
bring about meaningful change in all of
this will he bring people with him and
and that that's that's the risk does he
care about that perhaps not because his
audience is an American audience now as
we know and do we have a date for these
Court appearances yet they are all
coming up so summer before the
coronation summer after the coronation
and then they will take weeks some of
them will take weeks and weeks and weeks
Harry himself could give evidence though
I think there's a lot of suggestion that
certainly in the case against Mira group
newspapers he could he could come then
which would be huge to see him at the
high court but make no mistake
everything we've heard about William
throwing him to the grounds in
Nottingham Cottage is issues with
Camilla with his father with their
relationship with the press this this is
a big big deal for for Prince Harry you
cannot underestimate how strongly he
feels about this and how far he will go
in this fight with Fleet Street it's got
the makings of another Netflix
documentary doesn't it the prince versus
The Press is that something you see
happening no more Netflix documentaries
please please no more I'm sure there
could be a season two
um if we say it out loud maybe it won't
happen I don't know who knows I guess it
depends on how it ends
yes we know how it's starting anyway and
that's very soon but yeah where it goes
I I can't even begin to guess
well Laura we will no doubt revisit this
and speak to you regularly for this
Royal reality drama thank you so much
thank you thanks
my thanks to Graeme Johnson and Laura
bundock and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett our editor is Philly Beaumont
foreign